this is Jocko underground podcast number
49 sitting with here with Echo Charles I
wanted to talk about a little something
called Psychological reactants now this
is something that you know that I know
that I've known about for a long time
but I had but I haven't heard it
I didn't know this term
what this is is
the definition is quote unpleasant
motivation arousal or reaction
to offers people rules or regulations
that threaten or eliminate specific
behavior freedoms end quote
so what does that mean
what that means is
what that means is that people don't
like to feel their freedom of choice is
being threatened in any way
and what you hear I've heard me say for
years
and this is just something I would throw
out there as if it was a fact and it
kind of now is is you hear me say people
don't like have things imposed upon them
you don't want to impose your plan on
you don't force things on people that
there's a psychological
phenomenon that backs up that quote
feeling that I talk about
um this happens when you you know when
someone says hey you can't do that and
it makes you want to do it a little bit
yeah we were talking about something
earlier today it was like oh someone's
telling me to do something telling us to
do something and that makes us both of
us feel like oh we would just won't do
it just to spite them yeah
or at the very least you can tell me
what not to do like you're mad that you
can't do it even though you never wanted
to do it right that right there is that
right there is reactants that's
psychological reactance when someone
says hey you can't do that and it makes
you want to do it more and this is
because in my opinion humans don't like
to be controlled
right
humans don't like to be controlled we
tend to want to do the opposite of what
someone is imposing on us
this is by the way where the idea of
reverse psychology which everyone's
heard of
plays on that's that's the idea that
that it plays on like oh you you know
hey Echo you're not allowed to sweep up
in here no oh watch me I'm gonna sweep
up you know like the Tom Sawyer you know
example of you know you guys can't paint
the fence you know no yes we can okay
yeah okay fine so that's what's that's
what that's what reverse psychology
works on it works on reactants
uh there's four elements to reactants
or four I should say four stages maybe
perceived Freedom like this is what I
think I'm I should be allowed to do
threat to that freedom then you get the
reactants which then provides
restoration of the freedom
a couple interesting indicators the more
certain of the freedom
the harder the reactants so if it's
something you definitely think you
should be able to do and I told you not
do it you're gonna have even more
reactance to it the higher importance of
the freedom the more stringent the
reactants
and and here's an interesting point they
tie this to the fact that if I take one
Freedom away from you you
psychologically think if you take that
one you're probably gonna take more it's
almost like a a psychological slippery
slope that we're getting into
so it's important to understand this
it's important to understand this for me
to be able to sorta to sort of
quantify this idea that I've been
expressing for years
which is people don't like being told
what to do people don't like having
ideas imposed upon them people don't
like having plans imposed upon them
and and and so this is where it comes
from we all as humans have a
psychological reactance we don't want to
be told what to do we don't want to have
our freedom of choice
controlled in any way
so
then the question becomes how do you
overcome this right well this is again
something else I talk about all the time
using the indirect approach
making something someone's idea right I
don't push the idea down their throat I
ask Earnest questions to get them to say
oh well this a job well I think we
should do this right now oh yeah that
sounds like a great idea now it's been
your idea now we now you want to go and
execute it which is awesome
saying something like hey Echo here's
the situation we're in
I think we should go in this direction
but it's your call
right now I give you that little bit of
Freedom you go you know what here's what
I want to do and it allows you a little
bit more freedom to Think Through the
issue whereas if I say Echo you need to
do this right now you're automatically
against it and you might resist it you
might say I'm not going to do that
whereas if I say hey man here's the
situation it's your call what we do
and it opens up your mind to actually do
the right thing
and what this reinforces is the fact
that
once again the indirect approach
may seem
like the harder thing to do it may seem
like the less efficient thing to do but
this is another reason why
the shortest distance between two points
is not always a straight line in fact
you know that works on a piece of paper
in geometry class in sixth grade but in
the real world
the straightest the the closest distance
between two points is rarely if ever a
straight line and the indirect approach
is usually better
so there you go yeah the indirect you go
around the mountains kind of like okay I
was going up a big to Big Bear coming
back and my son he's five he goes why do
these roads have to be so windy because
they're windy yeah they are and he and
technically it's not a bad question it's
like yeah why isn't it why is it so
windy so you kind of did you say look
into freaking Cliff bro
no and I for sure didn't say it like
that but I did say however I was like oh
because they gotta go with the Contour
of the mountains otherwise like where's
the how are you gonna make the road
unless you made one huge Bridge or
something like this but that would take
a long time and buy all this stuff I
says but if you pay attention
this makes the most sense because you
gotta go look where we're going we're
always next to the mountain look and you
see him in for a long time he's just
looking at every curve and it's starting
to make sense to him it's true it's kind
of the same thing where it's like yeah
in a vacuum or in sixth grade geometry
or whatever yeah it's a straight line
but in real life it doesn't work like
that because there's all these other
factors yeah yeah that's uh kind of one
of the examples I'll use when I'm
talking to clients and trying to explain
the indirect approach to them you know
if you've got to get from point A to
point B
hey the easiest way is a straight line
right yes of course well what if there's
a river yeah what if there's a two Ridge
lines that you have to pass over and if
you just go a little bit off course you
can go over here into a nice field which
doesn't have the river running through
it and it doesn't have any Ridge lines
and instead of you you know instead of
it taking you
uh whatever 10 hours to get across the
ridgelines across the river you can just
you can just get there in three hours
because you can go fast you're not
gaining and losing elevation twice to
get over ridgelines you know and risking
some detrimental stuff yeah by the way
yeah so very interesting the indirect
approach I'm still trying
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen go
to Jocko underground.com And subscribe
and we're doing this to mitigate our
Reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
at Jocko underground.com and we'll get
you taken care of until then we will see
you mobilized
Underground